so I'm sitting here laying here actually
working watching the NBA finals and I
tweeted a little bit ago uh saying that
Facebook vanity URLs was going to be a
game changer and everybody you know a
lot of people greet actually on Twitter
but something really why I don't you
know here's why facebook fan pages with
vanity URLs can do so much more than the
average Twitter account because you can
customize a fan book page you can do a
lot of things with it so when you create
that call to action when you land
instead of just following somebody you
can do a lot of engagement you can do a
lot of things and another huge component
is the fact that Facebook vanity URLs
for the fan page are easy to remember
you know just like twitter.com slash
Oprah or Ellen or I am diddy led to
Twitter's explosion I always felt that
Facebook has been about six months slow
to releasing these because once you get
on TV or print or billboards or radio
very easy to remember facebook.com slash
Gary so you know coming this weekend
they're launching it I've been talking
about it behind the scenes for a couple
weeks I did that tweet and I'm watching
the NBA Finals and bam oh bam oh vitamin
water came through right there with the
facebook com vitamin water I think
Facebook has just created a scenario
where they're going to become so much
more important for anybody building
brand or storytelling because of all the
capabilities you can do once you get to
facebook.com slash vitamin water by the
way great commercial Dwight Howard and a
lot of big things coming from facebook
fan pages with these vanity URLs I know
I have it for Gary and I have it for
crush it and and I think a lot of brands
are going to really benefit quite a bit
from the flexibility once the user gets
there